In the next variation we
consider, all random variables
are continuous.
For this case, we do have
a Bayes rule, once more.
And we have worked [out]
quite a few examples.
So there's no point,
again, in going
through a detailed example.
Let us just discuss
some of the issues.
One question is when
do these models arise?
One particular class of models
that is very useful and very
commonly used are so-called
linear normal models.
In these models, we,
basically, combine
various random variables
in a linear function.
And all the random variables of
interest are now to be normal.
For instance, we might have
a signal, a noisy signal,
call it Theta, which is now
a continuous valued signal.
We receive that
signal, but corrupted
by some noise, which is
independent from what was sent.
And we wish to recover, on the
basis of the observation X,
we wish to recover
the value of Theta.
And then there are versions
of this problem that
involve Theta vectors
instead of single values.
So that Theta consists
of multiple components,
and where we obtain many
measurements X. We will,
actually, see in the
next lecture sequence,
a quite detailed discussion
of models of this type.
And this will be one
of our main examples
within our study of inference.
There will be another example
that we will see a few times,
and this involves
estimating the parameter
of a uniform distribution.
So X is a random variable that's
uniform over a certain range.
But the range itself
is random and unknown.
And on the basis
of observations X,
we would like to make
an estimation of what
the true value of Theta is.
This is an example
that you will see
in our collection of solved
problems for this class.
So what are the questions
in this setting,
we wish to come up with
ways of estimating Theta,
we form an estimator,
and the main candidates
for estimators at this
points are, once more,
the maximum a posteriori
probability estimator,
which looks at this
conditional density
and picks a value of theta that
makes this conditional density
as large as possible.
And then the alternative one
is the least mean squares
estimator, which just
computes the expected value
of Theta given X.
For any given
estimator, we then want
to characterize its performance.
In this case, a natural
notion of performance
is the distance between
our estimate, or estimator,
from the true value of Theta.
And commonly we use
the squared distance
and then take the average
of that squared distance.
So in a conditional universe
where we have already
observed some data,
we might be interested
in this particular
expectation, which
is the mean squared error of
this particular estimator,
given that we obtain
some particular data.
Or we can average over
all possible data points
that we might obtain
so that we look
at the unconditional
mean squared error, which
is a measure of the overall
performance of our estimator.
We will be talking
about these criteria
and the mean squared error
in a fair amount of detail
in a subsequent
lecture sequence.